[موسيقى]
لجعل المباني المقاومه للزلازل يمكن
اللجوء لعده طرق هندسيه في الاحوال
العاديه تتعرض الابنيه عاده للقوه
العموديه بسبب الجاذبيه وتكون الخرسانه
العاديه قادره على تحمل تلك الضغوط لكن في
حاله الزلازل فهي تتعرض لقوه افقيه كذلك
ولا تستطيع مقاومتها الخرسانات العاديه
غير المسلحه اي تلك التي لم تضف اعمده
الحديد لها ولذلك تعتمد البلديات في
البلدان ذات النشاط الزلزالي الكبير الى
وضع شروط اضافيه على المقاولين قبل منحهم
رخص البناء لضمان ان تكون الابنيه المنفذه
من طرفهم قادره على مقاومه الزلازل لاسيما
فيما يتعلق بزياده كميه الحديد المضافه
للخرسانات لتحمل القوه المنبعثه من
الزلازل كما ان هناك اساليب اخرى لزياده
قوه البناء وقدرته على الصمود مثل
باستخدام جدران القص وهي جدران خرسانيه
مسلحه تمتد من اساس البناء حتى اعلاه او
يمكن اعتماد تصميمات هيكليه من شانها نقل
القوات الافقيه الى الاساسات ومن ثم نقلها
الى الاعمده التي تتحمل القوات العموديه
كما يمكن استخدام اساسات مرنه تستطيع
امتصاص الهزات الارضيه والقوه القادمه من
اسفل البناء كل هذه الحلول يصممها
المهندسون بناء على حد ادنى لمقاومه
الزلازل تحدده البلديات عاده ويقوم
المتعهدون بتنفيذه لكن انهيار العديد من
المباني في تركيا خلال الزلزال الاخير رغم
انها انشئت وفق المعايير التي اقرت بعيده
زلزال ازميت عام
المتضمنه لشروط اكثر صرامه في معايير
البناء اثار العديد من التساؤلات بشان ما
اذا كان هناك التزام حقيقي بها ام ان
المقاولين ومتعهدي البناء التفوا على
المعايير ولجاوا لاستخدام كميات اقل من
الخرسانات المسلحه او مواد بناء رديئه
لتقليل التكاليف وزياده الارباح